[Music]
super nice to meet you thank you for
doing this
thanks for having me this is a pleasure
yeah you're you're super inspiring
everything that you do is really
incredible and it's a privilege and an
honor to be able to talk to you about it
and have you share a little bit about
your journey and your experience and I
think when I think about you obviously I
think about this incredibly talented
ultra runner but really what you're
about is so much more than that
and I think right now we can both agree
that the country is very divided there
is a communication gap there is this
division that is separating us and our
ability to communicate has broken down
our communities are fractured and the
path forward the healthy path forward is
to try to find a way to bridge that gap
to try to improve the health of our
communication right to to unite around
our shared value systems and beliefs and
and you've really leveraged your running
to try to promote this message and I
think it's beautiful the adage of you
can't know the world unless you know
you're back in your backyard I don't
know who originally said that did you
know who to whom is that quote
attributable I know it wasn't me yeah
somebody said that but you actually not
only took it to heart but put it into
practice and you're really more of an
artist than an athlete in my mind like
you have used this medium of running
great distances to paint this canvas of
humanity in a really beautiful way so
thank you for that thank you I
appreciate that yeah and you know I knew
about you for a long time and then
really dived into what you were doing
when you were when you were doing the
San Francisco every single Street thing
and I knew that you would run across
America but I didn't know that much
about that until I started prepping for
talking to you today and you sent me a
cut of the Transamerica
film which is really quite moving so how
did that come together the film or the
well is the trip itself let's just talk
let's talk about the trip and then we
can kind of weave in the film so the
trip itself two years ago I ran across
the country I left on March 1st of 2017
and finished on August 1st of 2017 so a
five-month trip the idea behind it is
that I've you know I've competed on a
national and international level I've
traveled all over the world pursuing
this this sport this running mountain
running trail running ultra running and
I was just kind of getting to a point in
my career where I needed to I needed to
explore what else the sport really meant
to me and what its potentials were and
that's kind of when I came to this
realization that I knew so many more
parts of the world than I do our own
country and such a huge part of that
realizing you know as you just said we
have this breakdown in communication you
know with this increase in in the the
bubble effect you know it's becoming
easier and easier to live within our own
bubbles it just occurred to me that such
a huge problem of ours right now is that
we're not talking to each other and
right and what better way to do that
especially for someone in my position
who can put in a lot of miles I don't
have the commitment of a family I've I
you know I don't have the commitment of
a nine-to-five job a standard job per se
what better way to really explore this
than to to do something that I've always
wanted to do which is to do a really big
Trek and how how many years in the
making was this I think that I could say
that it was almost 10 years 15 years in
the making but you know I when I was
nineteen years old I stopped going to
college for a couple years I one of my
goals during those two years off was to
to bike across the country and so I
saved up my money I took the Greyhound
bus up to Washington I had this idea
that I was going to bike around the
entire United States the circumference
of the United States
I made it three days and thought that I
had completely destroyed my knee and you
know this is with a serious road bike
with big gears and 60 or 70 pounds of
gear with me I completely destroyed
myself almost immediately so I packed up
my bike I sent it to Colorado and then I
took my money in my time and went to
Italy instead so that was 90 and I was
18 years ago
yeah it's funny like at the peak of your
you know sort of physical powers as a
young strapping young man you know on a
bike and your make it three days totally
and it's just I mean it's the classic
you know you're you know I was just not
mature enough to pursue something like
that and I just went way overboard so
it's been in my head since I was 19 I
read a book when or if not earlier I
read a book a walk across America Peter
Jenkins totally yeah when I was 17 or 18
or so uh-huh and that really stuck in my
head just this man's ability to connect
with people for no other reason than
he's out there on foot putting himself
in a vulnerable position yeah he really
kind of put that type of expedition on
the map his son Jedediah is a good
friend has been on the podcast a couple
times cool yeah yeah who's an amazing
writer if you read his his book it's
quite something yeah and I haven't read
that I'll check it out so I'd been
thinking about it for a while and then
very like the the real planning I
thought about I would say for a year to
two years ahead of time like if I'm
gonna do this like how how am I gonna
make it work for me
how would I want like it's not something
that I anticipate doing twice if you're
just gonna do this once how are you
going to make it worthwhile
and for me that meant really diving into
what America is and what I am personally
right and planning that beforehand and
so that means you know looking at all of
the history of the United States how we
came to be who we are you know that the
this this westward expansion this idea
of manifest destiny of display you know
that I call it the good the bad and the
ugly this this idea that you know we
created this country but we also we did
a lot of bad in the process and so you
know how can I pursue a massive feat
like this and touch upon all of those
things at the same time
how much did political news and the 2000
2016 election play into the urgency to
finally do this thing so I had the date
set in my head before the elections I
don't know why I picked March first and
he did a round number so I went with
with that I knew that I was gonna hit
weather at some point during during my
trip whether that be snow rain or
extreme heat so I had the date planned
before the election and like many of us
I think on both the right and the left I
thought that the election was going to
go a different way and then come
November 8th November 9th of 2016 when
it did go the way that it did I knew
that it was going to be way more
interesting yeah
then I had anticipated did that
influence the route because you you make
this decision to spend a lot of time in
the south and you go through you know
mostly red states over the course of the
whole journey
well it didn't influence the route so
much but I dare you to try and find a
route across the odds states where
you're not going through a lot of red
territory and that's the nature of the
country and that
but I think a lot of us have learned
over the past few years especially when
we're starting to look at the electoral
college and all these things is you know
the the center part of the country is
huge yeah you know it's it's a you know
there's a lot of space in between towns
but there's there's a lot of space in
general which accounts for a large
population right so it didn't influence
my route all that much but I did know
after the elections that it was going to
be really interesting I was gonna be you
know I I wanted to go through the South
because I've spent very little time in
the South I was raised by parents who
didn't necessarily have a prejudice
against the south but there was not a
lot of urgency to bring us there my mom
was a hippie in the 1960s hippie today
in 2019 and I think in the 1960s he had
this this common dialogue going on that
that warned people from going to the
South you know you've got Easy Rider
where you know you've got your
protagonists and meeting their end there
and and that's just just one of the few
different stories right so you just got
married right just got married a -
natraj oh thanks yeah that's very cool
you've been with Liz for like seven or
eight years or something like that
almost a decade of visiting Wow
but at the inception of this run my
sense is and you allude to this sort of
you you comment on it but you don't
spend too much time talking about the
fact that you're kind of going through a
bit of an existential crisis perhaps
about your relationship but perhaps
about things greater that motivated you
to kind of take a break from your
relationship and and carve out this time
for yourself so what was going on with
you kind of mentally and emotionally
going into the run it's something like
to this day that I don't know that I can
answer entirely other than it just
seemed like a trip to me it seemed like
a part of my life and a trip to me where
I needed to be on my own
and I don't know really a better way to
say that other than that I just I
couldn't fathom really thinking about
anyone other than myself
uh-huh during this time yeah in
retrospect I thought a lot about other
people and especially Liz and so it's
yeah it's it's a living learn thing I'm
glad that it has turned out the way that
it has and and that I think that we both
learned a lot from from that break that
we took and and yeah it's it's it was it
was definitely a challenge it was a
challenge then and and even looking back
on it it's it continues to be a
challenge when you know when you put a
little fracture in a relationship like
that you know as well as it as you can
repair it it's it's still there yeah so
it's it's something too for me for us to
always think about and for me to be able
to to tell other people as well you know
that's a something and that you know
when people are having issues with their
relationships our tendency is to go
inward rather than outward and and I
don't think we really talked enough
about about mistakes that we've made or
issues that we've had and you know I
think that that's really important for
for me to put that out there right and
there's something about running and that
solitude that accompanies it that gives
you the space and the capacity to kind
of wrestle with those things and and get
clarity for yourself I mean you have
there's a monologue in the in the film I
think it's after you've left Aspen and
you're in the you're in the snow and
then the Rockies where you say you know
look running was about competition for
most of my life measuring myself against
others and a clock but it's become a
process of not just connecting with
other humans but a process of
self-discovery and that's like a huge
theme and in everything that you do and
and in this beautiful movie yeah and I
think that I think if most of us most of
us that do run or walk or
like or pursue something with
consistency year after year I think if
we really look at what it's doing for us
I think that a lot of us will find the
same things right and this is this is
something that I tell people and you
know running is has been my thing but I
don't think that's necessarily the thing
for everybody I think that writing
knitting could be that thing crochet you
know badminton like I I just think for
me I chose this activity 20 over 20
years ago 25 years ago and I've stuck
with it for 25 years and when you will
stick with something for that long
whether it's it's an activity or a
person you're gonna continue to learn so
much more about that but also and more
importantly you're gonna learn so much
more about yourself and write this this
thing just keeps changing and changing
and changing and it's that consistency
that allows for that to to happen right
so lots of people have run across
America yeah I just had brought this guy
Robby Ballinger on the show who did it
last year he did it in like 75 days my
friend Mike Posner just walked across
America but most people that do this do
it with an RV and a lot of supports that
and that support tends to be off-camera
but you you decide to do this
unsupported and for a vast majority of
the entire expedition it's just you with
a very light backpack and a tarp and a
ground cloth and a little bit of food
and basically that's it yeah so I mean
I've been at this sport for quite a
while I wouldn't say that I have a huge
following but I do have people that are
paying attention to what I'm doing and
for me personally it doesn't seem right
to to put this project out there in a
way that I don't think is accessible to
a normal person and by that I mean I
don't think most people can
pulled together an RV in the funds to
pay for a person and gas and food for
multiple people for months on end
conversely I do think that people a lot
of people ideally if you're if you're
younger and you have the physical
capability can put together the funds
and the time to to do it in the same way
that I did I mean maybe you're not doing
like there's a there's a little bit of
an irony in there because you're like
I'm gonna do this super EXTREME thing to
show that how doable it is for everybody
yeah and maybe not everybody but I do
believe you know they've got several
thousand people starting the Appalachian
Trail these days and I think the
Appalachian Trail is awesome like
there's no doubt about it but like how
much are you really gonna learn about
you're gonna learn a lot about yourself
and you're gonna learn a lot about Trail
culture but how much are you really
going to learn about the United States
in this greater context it's it's a form
of escapism and that sometimes exactly
what we need is to escape what's going
on outside of outside of our front door
but for me personally like I needed to
explore something a lot deeper right
than just myself and just you know the
the physical capabilities of something
like that so so I I set a budget for
myself I did a thousand dollars a month
five thousand dollars total for the five
months
I slept outside most nights I'd get a
hotel or a motel once once a week or
once every ten days that increased more
towards like once every couple days
towards the end as I started kind of
losing it a little bit you know simply
needed to go into a room and lock the
door and turn the AC on and and turn
some mindless television on but for the
most part what I wanted to do was to to
put it out there that this is something
that yeah people can do and that there's
alternatives to these to do in the
Appalachian Trail or go into Europe for
four months like you can just pack a
very light backpack and
and see what's out there and aha and
it's it's really incredible when you you
know when people see that all you have
is in your backpack and they ask you if
you've got a gun you know to protect
yourself and and like no I don't have a
gun - you know just putting yourself out
there in a vulnerable position the
amount of warmth and generosity that I
experienced was was something that I
never could have anticipated in a
million years people given me every last
dollar from their wallet you know and
there's the guy what's his name James
Steele yeah yeah you eighty bucks or
100's I said a hundred eighty it was I
said eighty it was 100 hundred sixty
right one hundred and sixty dollars and
he wasn't taking no for an answer no it
was amazing it was and that's when I
kind of realized you know that people in
their own way want to participate in
this in this thing a few years ago so
this is kind of something that I think
about and the best way for me to to tell
this is is to talk about someone else
running across the country and that was
Pincus Ptolemaic who did across the
country and 40 I'm gonna say 44 days it
could have been a little quicker this is
in 2016 so a year before her a few
months before I did mine he did this and
he was doing 60 to 70 miles a day for 45
days and broke the the record that had
stood for unsupported he that was very
supported those three RVs with several
people yeah it was is it is a big effort
for a lot of people and and he he's sure
to give them credit as well yeah but for
me personally so I I was in Wisconsin at
the time and I saw that he was going
through northern Illinois and I got in
my car and drove a two and a half hours
just to run with him for a few miles cuz
it's like I just felt like it was seeing
this mythical creature when someone's
doing something like that and even now
to this day like now that I've done this
big journey
like I still think it's a mythical
creature yours it's like seeing a
mountain lion or something yeah yeah and
so I think that for me that's what it
that's what it was for kind of when I
came to realize that some people when
they they wanted to give me money or
just stop and talk it was like you know
it is something rare right there's the
one guy who it looks like he turned his
car around when he saw you and he got
out he's like my friends gonna freak out
I read about you like when you cross the
state line or something like that
yeah there was some awareness as you
were passing through what you were doing
totally in in certain areas I don't know
why it was in certain areas it was
Oklahoma and Arkansas where I received
the most amount of generosity and warmth
and then when I got to California
ironically like that like I think what I
appreciate most is is you know there is
a there's a vein of humility and
vulnerability that that infuses you know
this effort and the other things that
you've done and this trans Americana
journey is almost like this performance
art piece that is part de tocqueville
part Henry David Thoreau like I'm gonna
light out on America and learn about
democracy and connect with people to try
to better understand them better
understand myself and better understand
you know what is required to unite us
and bring us together totally yeah took
your time yeah the priority wasn't the
running the priority was the connection
yeah and in the funniest thing that I
encountered or the most interesting
thing that I encountered when I went
across the country is that like I
thought I would be talking politics all
the time
mm-hmm and it never came up it was just
like you when when you're doing
something like that when people see
something like that they don't want to
ask you what your political views are
they want to ask you about like what
you're doing what you're seeing out
there and and and and it just becomes
really incredible that so much of this
stuff just kind of dissolves away
and and you realize that and I think I
say the same thing in in the movie
coming out is that I think we're I don't
think so I know so we're way more
similar than we are different yeah it's
uh I think that were 90% similar and 10%
different in that 10 percent difference
has become inflated so that we think
that it's 90 percent but it's not right
it's exploited example and it's
leveraged by the media to further divide
us totally and and you know I subscribe
to my own media and a lot that's been
brought to my attention over the past
couple years with talk of fake news and
all of these things is is coming to
terms with that the media that I pay
attention to is also biased uh-huh and
and it's not just Fox News like NPR is
also biased we've all got these biases
and and you know we like to think that
we're right about our convictions but
the reality is is that you know there's
a million different paths out there yeah
and if you grew up in Kansas and on a
farm in Kansas and and you had that
lifestyle and you know there's that I I
just see their voting habits their
convictions as every bit as valid as
mine and that's probably the biggest
thing that that I gained from from my
run across the countries is coming to
terms with that yeah did it change your
your media diet in any way did it expand
like what you expose yourself to or
contract that or you know what is the
lingering kind of long term impact
because this was a couple years ago yeah
so you've had time to reflect otally
have some objectivity on it and it has
and let's see how do I put this it's
it's just made me pay attention to other
forms of media and it doesn't
necessarily I don't necessarily
subscribe to them but being aware that
these that Fox News is out there and
that this is where my dad gets his
information and in that if I can allow
myself to believe that you know maybe
NPR
or whatever it is that I pay attention
to I don't necessarily believe this but
if if I can believe that NPR is is just
as biased as Fox News is based on on you
know our polarized convictions right and
in the agenda behind them then that's
then that's what's stuck with me from
from that trip at least in terms of my
attention to media right so you start in
South Carolina and there's this crazy
great scene where you sell your car for
$1000 and then you have to pay her to
give you a ride to the beach yeah and
she doesn't she couldn't care less what
you were doing she's just totally
disinterested and like unflappable about
the whole experience and there it's very
unceremoniously you begin you kind of
dip your toe into the ocean and then
you're like alright I guess we're
starting now yeah and that's it totally
I mean there's yeah I don't know there's
no real way to start a trip like that
and yeah I don't I didn't want anyone
there I did have a videographer there
right my friend Jared with the wandering
fever who's making this film with
Solomon my main sponsor as as the backer
behind it and I was grateful to have him
he rented a car so after we sold that
car he rented a car and I had backup for
the first six days which was just really
nice it was a nice soft way to enter
this journey but yeah it's it's a I mean
it's just crazy starting a trip like
that it's like you really do that that
that quote definitely emerges the trip
of a thousand miles begins with a single
step and right like that first step is
just like so weren't why it's just like
yeah and then there's another spat then
yeah yeah it's just doing this yeah
exactly and then and then you get to the
end of the first day and like I only did
like 13 miles that day and I got
completely fried sunburned fried uh-huh
and on day one blisters like sunburn
hungry like everything right
it's just like wow alright alright it's
gonna be yeah adventure well it seemed
like most of the most profound
encounters that you had with human
beings took place during that like tour
of the South like from South Carolina
through Oklahoma is where you connected
the most with people and then it's then
you kind of enter this you know phase
where the expanses of nature begin to
you know just get bigger and bigger and
those encounters are fewer and fewer and
then like you're in Aspen and you do a
reset where you're home with your family
and your friends and it almost felt like
all the questions that you were asking
of yourself and of others had kind of
been answered at that point like every
every intention that you went into this
run you know in terms of like things
that you wanted to solve for yourself or
discover or learn had kind of been
resolved in answered yeah
but yet you have this whole you know
actually the hardest part of the whole
thing still remained for you to do was
there a moment where you were like I
don't need to get to California like
I've kind of satisfied myself here there
was yeah I would say that I can safely
say that there was no moment where that
actually occurred to me it was just kind
of like I don't know it's like going
down the Grand Canyon or going through
the rapids or something it's like you're
halfway through the rapids and you're
like that was fun
but it's like there's no there's no
getting out there's no getting off the
river and that's that was my mentality
right and I think it was in in terms of
completing the goal that was the best
mentality to have from my personal
health and my mental sanity it probably
wasn't the best mhm
but it did bring me to a place that I I
couldn't have anticipated or gotten to
otherwise yeah and I still think about
it a lot to this day two years later
just like the state of mind that I ended
up getting into in in the desert you
know in the depths of it
just kind of this this full emptiness of
self and right and you start to think
about other you know some some very big
names throughout the course of human
history who have tested themselves in
the desert and for for long periods of
time and and growing up Catholic the
first one obviously to come to mind is
Jesus in the desert for forty days and
I'm not overly religious anymore but
it's something that I think about in
that sense is like you know how accurate
that story is or how much you want to
interpret that story like the body and
the mind goes through some really
serious changes when you're in the
desert for that long and you start to
lose it a little bit and you just start
to become really empty and you're almost
your ego as truly becomes dissolved and
yeah and you just have this goal to get
across it and then you start doing and
not thinking and it's it's a really
beautiful thing well it's like a
purification right it's like you've
you've traversed a huge section of the
country you've been enriched through all
these experiences that you've had and
all these people that you've met along
the way and now in order for you to
become whole we got to strip you down to
your you know we're gonna take you
through this section of the country that
is gonna basically beat you down and
burn you to a crisp
until you you're forced to meet yourself
in the most profound way that you ever
have before and then you can reassemble
all these pieces and emerge from this
experience like transformed totally like
it's it's it is biblical in a certain
respect and it's also this kind of you
know hero's journey like you're not done
yet now the final phase we're gonna put
you through this thing yeah and see if
you can weather this totally and it's
not permanent which is kind of a bummer
that purification of the soul if that's
what we're gonna call it it's not
permanent yeah like you've finished the
trip and
back to resetting totally it's like
right what do I do with and this is
where I'm I'm curious to talk you know
or listen to two other people that have
gone through similar sort of things like
how how do you put your life together
after this you're not going to keep
walking forever
in the end it's it's funny I you know of
course any you tell anybody that you
went across the country on on foot and
and nine times out of ten they're
they'll say oh he like Forrest Gump and
of course you're like oh yeah yeah force
okay that was that was a movie but yes
but there is the scene in the movie
where he just like you can see it's like
it's very real like he he has purified
himself and he just stops in the desert
and he says he's done it's gone home
right it's like there's nothing else to
be done I figure if I found everything
that I was looking for yeah I like it
gives me goosebumps right now it's kind
of funny to think about Forrest Gump
even after I've I've done that and to
[Music]
recognize those similarities uh-huh
and just and the the astuteness of the
film itself in putting that in there
right and just have like not labeling it
overtly but having it there and just
seeing like he was it was done like
human life there was nothing there was
nothing more to be gained from from that
journey right but you are not in the
desert and you did not have that
epiphany in that moment no well is it is
most people's only frame of reference
code or anything that you're doing and
rather than be annoyed by that I'm going
to be able to embrace it and say
actually that was profound yes yeah I am
I am retracing those steps in that way
the on this journey yeah which is cool
of all the encounters that you had along
the way what are the ones that that
stick with you so there was that one
this is in the film Jim Steele who
literally emptied out every dollar his
wallet and gave it to me and
that was quite profound that was in
Arkansas on a particularly miserable day
I could remember like I was in between
two towns one was called quit man and I
suppose you would bounce equipment and
the other was I forget what the other
town was but it was like in a day where
if I was really paying attention to the
what the the universe was telling me to
do it was telling me to quit man and
right this guy is pulls up and and just
as he said in the spirit that it's given
just gave me on every dollar out of his
pocket was he driving along the road and
he was yeah he was driving along the
road and and pulled up alongside of me
and saw me with my backpack and my beard
and and asked if I was running across
the country and I said I want to talk to
you
uh-huh and he was up ahead another two
hundred meters and and we just had a
short conversation but I think it was
equally as impactful for both of us
another one was in the middle of the
Nevada desert there's this on highway 50
in Austin Nevada there's this bar there
called the Serbian Christmas bar or
something like that and there's this
Serbian man that that runs the that owns
the restaurant and there was it was just
funny to find an article written about
him they were the article was about
highway 50 but then it focused in on
this man and I found this article and
and just talking about how racist and
terrible of a human being this guide is
and and so went in there and had several
beers with him and and had a great time
and heard his perspective and and tried
to take it in as best I could but you
know still in the end walked away with a
new friend mmm
gosh there was so many along the so I
did a section of rivers so you were
asking like kind of how this how I came
up with the idea of this run or and one
of the things like
I did about a thousand miles of trail to
2500 miles of of road and 300 miles of
river and did the Tennessee River going
across Alabama in the spirit of American
westward expansion
it's very Huckleberry Finn yeah Huck
Finn and also Lewis and Clark Lewis and
Clark did about a thousand miles of
river up river they went up I believe
the Mississippi and then to the Missouri
they went up the route the Missouri
quite a ways before setting off on land
but just trying to get a feel for that
you know when you can take advantage of
water you do and so I was going down the
river for a couple days and at that
point three or four days and I just
about to cross into Alabama and needed
to get some food from Pittsburg
Tennessee South Pittsburg Tennessee and
pulled on to this private dock and
almost have got my wet sleeping bag out
my paddle board up on on this dock and
this fancy car drives up right then and
I'm like oh gosh this is the the
landowner and sure enough it was and and
he had read an article that was
published in the Memphis Tennessee I
can't remember the name of the sorry
Chattanooga Tennessee I can't remember
the name of the newspaper but he just
comes up to me he says are you that
skinny boy running to San Francisco I
said yes sir I am
he's like I'm taking you to supper and
so we get in his car and then he drove
me into town he's the fourth-generation
CEO owner of cat of lodge cast iron the
the the skillets mmm and took me all
over town towns about a thousand people
introduced me to the entire staff in the
office they all thought I was a bit
kooky but he this guy is like mid-70s
and and just like you could tell was a
total character uh-huh and just wanted
to talk about rivers and and
how he's coming to the end of his his
time at the at the company and and he's
gonna go start doing big river trips and
Wow and so that was really awesome and
give you a bed to sleep in that night no
I had to keep going yeah I would have he
would have and I would have taken him up
on it but I I it was midday right and so
I needed to keep going and he pulled out
a hundred dollars out of his pocket and
said can I give this to you and I said I
you know I really don't need it I saved
up my money and and 75 years old the guy
gives me knuckles and he's like right on
wow yeah it's kind of like you're this
Western manifest destiny version of the
Buddhist ascetic you know who basically
is relying on the kindness of strangers
to survive yeah did you do work were
there opportunities that where people
were opening up your their homes and
letting you crash there for the night
and stuff like that
totally yeah yeah one in particular
memorable one was in on the Osage
reservation in Oklahoma north eastern
Oklahoma and I had gotten to this town
space in the name of the town right now
but got there was buying a couple beers
at the the store and this guy behind me
in line he that's what it was I was
asking the the clerk because I'd spent
the previous night out in the rain and I
just I wanted a nice dry spot to sleep I
wasn't looking for anything other than a
dry spot and and she's like yeah I don't
know the bridge over there is it's okay
but I think it's pretty rocky there and
and this guy behind behind me in line he
just looks at me and he says you're not
gonna so long as you don't steal
anything and you don't go into my
brother's room who owns the place you
can stay with me brother man and he had
a 12-pack of beer and and we went back
to his place and talked for the next
four and a half hours
and I can't imagine the set of
circumstances that would have to arise
for me to invite like a stranger who's
in line with me at some store back to my
house yeah - crash yeah I mean like
we've lost that maybe that's a
small-town thing and it seems like a
small gesture but that's kind of a big
thing it is a big thing yeah and it was
in in I it seems to me that I
encountered that way more like that sort
of generosity I can count on that way
more in the south and then less so as I
got into the West and so yeah I don't I
don't know what that says about us or
about the south or maybe what do you
make of America is your summation
so I mean after that trip I thought
America was great and I still do to this
day and it definitely yeah it rekindled
this love that I that I have for this
country and and I just think that I mean
I'm not gonna go out preaching to
everybody to go run or walk across the
country but running across our or county
or or whatever it is you know can can do
a lot
well we not everyone's gonna run across
America a very few are but everybody has
the ability to more profoundly connect
with their neighbors totally and I think
that's that's what I take away from it
that there are all little things that we
can do every single day to try to bridge
this divide a little bit better than we
have and I think such a huge part of it
is like physically getting out there and
meeting people and its really
uncomfortable like initially it's really
uncomfortable well you have the ultimate
icebreaker yeah it's like when you open
up with like this is what I'm doing like
everyone's gonna want to talk to you
totally but you strike me it's not like
you're this this super outgoing person
like you're you're kind of a quiet guy
right like was that uncomfortable for
you to be that open and vulnerable and
and like roll up on strangers when
you're passing through it wasn't you
know going back to this this myth of the
mountain lion when when you I mean you
really start to embody that like you
really start to feel like you are
something special
even though it's it's it's not lasting
for that long it's just lasting for the
few months that you're doing it and then
you know when it's done it's something
that you have done it's no longer
something that you are doing there so
while you are doing that thing I found
that it was really quite easy for me to
you know to go into a bar and and kind
of puff up my chest and say I'm running
across the country who's buying me a
beer
lots of free beers oh yeah yeah so yeah
and then when and then when it's over
you that's that's where the real work I
think begins at least for the individual
is like what do you do with this thing
that you have done that you are no
longer doing right well I mean I don't
know if you think of yourself or call
yourself an artist I certainly do and
and you know part of being an artist the
definition of art and being an artist is
to perceive the world through your
unique lens and then translate it using
some form of medium to elucidate a
greater truth about humanity or the
world right and that can come in a
variety of forms it can it can be in the
analog like encounters that you're
having when you're running across
America but you do it in many ways like
you're very much a storyteller through
photography through films or your mean
the writing on your website I'd never
been to your website before your website
is super cool like it the way it's I
mean it's laid out so minimally and
beautifully but everything that you've
written on it and the visual aesthetic
of it like it speaks to that artistic
sensibility and the storytelling aspect
of what you've done is super important
and I I'm sure there's no it's no
mistake that that this film you know
still hasn't come out to yours since
you've done the run like the amount of
work to try to get it right and tell the
story that you want to tell totally and
I'm looking over at this book here that
you have open water published by
Chronicle Books I'm going to shamelessly
promote that I've got a book coming out
about this as well you do cool five
Chronicle oh good when it's time spring
April 2020 okay then I can Corral you to
come back here wonderful yeah more
perfect but yeah it's you know that in
and I had both the film and the movie in
mind before I started this trip and
that's it was it was part of my packing
it was like I want to be able to like I
don't want to just do this for me I'm
doing this for a lot of people that
don't have the ability whether it's
physically whether it's money whether
it's family time any number of things
like how do i how can I share this with
as many people as possible in as
positive a way as possible and so yeah I
don't know if I've totally embraced the
title of artist yet I think that I I
mean I studied sociology and photography
in school and with photography certainly
talked a lot about art it's it's such a
technical pursuit that you're oftentimes
talking about technique rather than the
meaning behind all of all of what you're
shooting but that element has always
been there for me and yeah and your
wife's an artist she is yeah very much
living like an artist collective totally
out of phase just embrace yes I'll show
I'll shift my my resume or well when I'm
watching the movie I'm thinking about
the logistics of how you pulled this off
not just not the not in addition to the
run like how you managed the workflow of
like capturing all of this I would
imagine a lot of it's on iphone but you
had cameras with you and I'm thinking
how many SD cards did he bring and how
is he keeping the batteries charged and
you know what is he doing with all the
footage to make sure that it doesn't get
wet and ruined and yeah all that kind of
stuff
well I went through I destroyed I think
at least two and I think probably three
Sony rx100 s I'm surprised they still
give me the the insurance deal on them
because I buy those at a thousand bucks
a pop and 100 billion and a hundred
bucks on the insurance and on
never last me for more than six months
but they're they're great cameras
chest-mounted GoPro and then the iPhone
and yeah I was just kind of funny at
times they're like you know when I've
got literally several weeks of footage
on my person it no longer is anything
worth anything except for those there's
cards there and you know are they in
ziplock bags and super like how are you
pretty well you had I mean there's a lot
of beautiful cinematography and
incredible drone shots and the like so
you had a crew that would like drop in
for short periods right totally so I
have Jared so with the wandering fever
Dean Leslie and his wife Hannah are
there an incredible artistic couple that
have done most of Solomon's running
films over the last eight or nine years
I've worked with Dean on a whole bunch
of projects we've been on five different
continents together and so this was
definitely a new route for us for me to
shoot a lot and just hand that over and
then and then he sent out his assistant
Jared to join me for for at the
beginning for one week and then in the
middle in Colorado for three weeks and
into the desert and then at the end for
four days mm-hmm
and so it was yeah you're just kind of
keeping your fingers crossed that you're
getting everything for me personally it
was a challenge to you know on the worst
of days to pull out the camera and
pointed at myself and and talk to myself
or talked to an audience when I'm
feeling borderline crippled to set the
camera up and run back and forth in
front of the camera yeah there wasn't
kind times where I was like he put the
camera there and then went back and ran
by it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah some
outtakes would be hilarious the camera
falling to the ground and right yeah but
I was yeah having now seen the evolution
of the film I
I'm grateful for all that we did put
into it were there times it has to be
awkward at times when you're having
these encounters with people to pull out
a camera and say can i document this
yeah it was awkward at times people I
only got turned down twice yeah and
people were pretty chill about it I
think they appreciated again what I was
doing and and you know they'd ask what
it was for and I say well I might make a
movie about this but really I just want
to remember the people that I'm meeting
along the way mm-hmm and what's the plan
with the movie I mean as of today it's
not it's not how publicly yeah yeah well
keeping our fingers crossed it's been
submitted to a couple of the the bigger
independent film fest
here in the states and so that would
that's kind of the ultimate goal is to
see it on the big screen and in Austin
or in in New York City so yeah if any of
you guys are out there yeah it's an hour
and 15 minutes or something like that so
a little bit shorter than a typical
nonfiction documentary but but much
longer than anything you've done
prepared early yeah yeah well let's talk
about run Everett the run every street
thing yeah because the the the trans
Americana was taking this very thin line
across America in many ways you know
just circumstances dictating that you
have to keep it somewhat on a surface
level and the running every street in
San Francisco thing which really put you
on the map and created like a media
frenzy was a different version of that
that allowed you to go deep Ryan you
like more immerse yourself in your
community on that same theme of you know
you can't know the world unless you know
you know your neighborhood and you're
like I live here like let me learn this
totally and people think of San
Francisco as a relatively small city not
the case if you're gonna run every
street totally so how did that idea come
to you so that that actually came to me
almost immediately after running across
the country so
Liz and I got back together we got back
together as I was running across the
country we started discussing you know
where's next she was we were in
Wisconsin where she was doing her MFA
program and and she had a couple great
job prospects in San Francisco and I can
again kind of live anywhere so I I
signed up for that and we moved back to
the Bay Area and and it was really kind
of in my recovery time from running
across the country where I was sitting
up in the the Berkeley Hills at this
really cool house that we had scored for
for the summer and out on the porch
there where you're looking at everything
from Mount Tam to Sausalito Golden Gate
Bridge the Bay Bridge downtown San
Francisco you're looking down the
peninsula you're looking at Oakland and
Fremont
you know you've you've got a view of a
population of 2 million people and so
much Commerce so much transportation
coming and going really it was I'm not
going to call it the opposite of my
experience that I had just stunned going
across the country but in terms of the
space and the solitude that I had
experienced doing 4050 miles a day
running across the country it was so
dense and still so completely foreign to
me you know to have had such a massive
experience such as running across the
country and then look it down at this
human hive of 2 million people and kind
of realizing that like my experience was
so limited with what I had just done and
that if you really want to get to know a
country a place like this is such a
critical part of it as well as is
getting to know the densest part the the
place where where humans actually
congregate in mass
and so that's when I'm looking at that
and and I'm like why they all right so
how many how many miles of street are
there in San Francisco like if you're
you know it's it's a reasonably it's a
compact city it's got very strict
borders it's a seven by seven mile
square and you know I start so I started
doing my research how many miles I
earned I think it said eleven hundred
and fifty miles of street or eleven
hundred miles of street in San Francisco
and so I'm like okay that's from
approximately Denver to San Francisco
like I know how far that is I know how
long that could potentially take me like
what would that be like
and then more research I find that San
Francisco Chronicle writer journalist
had done exactly that yeah he walked it
over about seven years time and wrote
like two or three different articles
about it and and I was immediately
inspired would you get in touch with
that guy I tried my very best sleuthing
ever I called his name is John Graham
and I called probably ten different John
Graham's uh-huh not was a cold call cold
call yes like iBooks totally it was it
was like and I even contacted the
Chronicle I contacted a lot of people
and try to him he'd move to a different
part of California and and so I looked
for him there and like his age I never
never talked to him I'd still love to
talk to him I I don't know if he knows
that I'm sure he knows now I would hope
so it's like because it is very
inspiring and and his writings on it
were ended up becoming very similar to
my impression right and so so yeah I I
wanted to take the same approach but do
it ultra runner style and just massive
miles every day and
and and see you know because if if he's
if he took seven years to do it a city
can completely change in seven years
especially a city like San Francisco you
got to start over and do it again
totally and but what's what's if you can
do it in in six weeks or two months I
feel like you're getting a snapshot of
that place at that moment in time right
just looking at the grid of San
Francisco when you were embarking on
this I thought like well first of all
like how do you even figure out how
you're gonna do this route and do it in
a sane like well-planned manner and I
realize like that's a super complicated
equation to solve but when I started
digging into it more getting ready to
talk to you today I realized oh it's
even way more complicated than I would
have imagined and you sought out the
advice or the counsel of like a friend
of yours who was a professor right who
like works in computer mapping or
something like that to help you figure
out like the best way to approach this
yeah and so we we have 70 emails back
and forth from each other from my run of
San Francisco it was it was every single
day I was communicating with him his
name's Michael OD we were on the
cross-country team together and in high
school he's he's a brilliant human being
and he loved the idea that I was that I
was going for this like a literal human
guinea pig for this equation that he's
been thinking about before I even
mentioned it to him and in the end I
used very little of his information
really yeah because and for and it
wasn't because his information was bad
it is because of so many different
variables like you like translating the
equation into useable terms for myself
and so like how do you do that you put
it in Google Maps or you put it in like
there's this app called
map my run or letna I forget what
they're called but they actually can
talk to you from your phone like take a
left here at the end of this block turn
around
and it's San Francisco's too dense for
that to actually work for it to be for
it to work seamlessly mm-hmm and so or
you know if you got off the route so it
would program a 10-mile loop is what
they call it because you are starting
and finishing in the same place even
though it doesn't look at all like a
loop if you got off your loop at all
you're on mile 2 and then like only one
block away you might be on Mile five the
equation would skip those three miles
and just and but then it would ruin my
entire plan throw hay and so I ended up
just I found that it was for me
personally it was easier to have a map
in my hand and kind of figure out my
route throughout the day and it was like
it actually became kind of fun like I'm
not a puzzle person like crossword
puzzles or the Rubik's Cube I've never
solved solved a Rubik's cube in my life
but when you when it when it gets
translated into running terms and you're
actually running this crossword puzzle
or this rubik's cube and if you do it
well then it'll take you 25 miles if you
do it poorly it's gonna take you 28
miles like at the end of the 25 mile day
those three extra miles that's a big re
is huge incentive for you to get this
problem right uh-huh
and so it was it became really exciting
and I got really good at it yeah you
have to be this cartographer urban
archeologist yep to solve it and it's
interesting but so so this professor was
like crunching algorithms to solve it
but ultimately you you went more a
little bit more on like feel and tactile
printed out maps and things like that
totally in in like there's just a lot of
things that like that he couldn't
possibly account for and when some of
these can't park your cart your van
there for all day or so delete you can
that's one thing you park your car there
or you know it would make sense for for
the sake of the algorithm to go across
this street and do like two or three
blocks and if
neighborhood and which you would
therefore not have to do on a different
day but it would ruin the entire feel of
that day like you're very much like a
huge street like market going down the
center of San Franci staying within and
like a sub ecosystem exactly I'm
crossing into a different kind of like
cross-section of humanity that's a very
good way to put it yeah and and so I
didn't I didn't really want to do that
and so he would figure out you know so
this is those 70 emails back and forth
is him not just figuring out a good
algorithm but figuring out what Ricky
wants and so you were you sleeping in
your van at night or were you going home
up to the Berkeley Hills so I ended up
sleeping in so I've the long story short
a couple European friends came over to
the states wanting a van I helped them
buy a van I had no intention of using
this van I was just gonna sell it when
they left and when they left is when
this project started and that's when I
realized like this is going to say to
them yeah this is gonna save me two
hours a day of driving when I'm gonna be
extremely tired and I like didn't want
to deal with traffic and so I ended up
sleeping in my van for most of it and
Liz would come into the city and camp
out in the city you know in the you know
urban camping I I I should have and I
probably still can come up with an
amazing map of the best camp spots in
San Francisco dropper like places where
you can be up on a hill with your door
open looking at stars and and the city
skyline and completely safe and so yeah
it was a really cool part of it and then
of course just being able to just to end
my day you know right there and then
start the next day right there and you
never had to worry about hydration or
food right did you just go into
restaurants and eat or how did you
manage like the calories almost entirely
restaurants yeah in in Chinatown it was
yep Chinese food and and the son said it
was Vietnamese and fun in the mission it
was tacos lots of talk arise and yeah
and I never I again carried two
different cameras with me in order to be
able to document all of it so I had the
Sony rx100 and then a little GoPro and
then my cell phone so I guess I had
three cameras yeah and we should say
Solomon made a film out of that called
every single street will give the same
people that worked on that trans
Americana
totally yeah the wandering fever huh
yeah and it was it was a really fun film
to work on just kind of it was different
than going across the country because
you know we were talking about how I
when I was running across the country
like I didn't even have to tell people
or if I did want to tell people right
you know it was like people were
immediately interested in what I was
doing this was completely the opposite
you know yeah exactly who cares exactly
you know but but your ability to
interact with people is a hundredfold
higher yeah you're just surrounded by
people the entire time
totally so what were those encounters
like like how did what was similar and
what was different about the
interpersonal you know encounters
experiences that you had yeah they were
a lot shorter they weren't all admit
they for the most part they weren't as
deep it's just the nature of living in a
city and that's part of what I wanted to
discover on on something like that is
you know the the city you're just packed
like it's constant stimulation and
that's people that's cars that's noise
it's food like all of these things stuff
you would have killed for when you're
running across a desert totally yeah
with the exception of like you know the
the the lack of intimacy and I think
that that speaks a lot to what a city is
a lot of people for me personally like
if I want to go get lost like I go out
into the mountains and that's my that's
my quiet spot that's where I go to be by
myself for a lot of people that spaces
the city like that's they appreciate the
anonymity
being in the city and and how nobody
nobody really looks at you know but he
really cares you know I think that's
really a safe place for a lot of people
there was also a long way in alienating
totally yeah that's the flip side of
that coin and so it's uh so yeah I was I
would say my most powerful interactions
with people in San Francisco where were
homeless people and and I think a huge
part of that was this dedication or not
on my part I'm can be just as guilty of
this as the next person
and that's to ignore this problem but
when you're running certain streets in
San Francisco dead-end street in the
middle of soma like there's absolutely
no reason to go to the end of that
dead-end street unless you go in there
to to shoot up and then pass out mm-hmm
and so when I find myself there and
there's people there what are you gonna
do say hey how you doing mm-hmm and they
they look at you looking at them and and
you and you can have a conversation
maybe you don't I never felt in in
danger by any means
I certainly have it on my side that I'm
you know young white male well a guy and
running shoes isn't very threatening
totally it's not like an alarm bell
sounding off if you're running around
but you know you're putting yourself in
precarious situations yeah but never any
you never had any brushes with danger no
it was a yeah maybe like on my final day
running through the Tenderloin in in San
Francisco like eight or nine o'clock at
night this guy I came around a corner
and and he like threw a fake punch at me
I get my face and just stopped right
short and he was just sizing me up that
was like his and and when when he saw
that I did I didn't even flinch and the
reason that I didn't flinch is because I
just run 48 or 49 miles that day and I
was completely exhausted and like I
don't think it really would have
mattered to me if he did knocked me out
that probably would have been a nice end
to that day you just you just said
alright well in part inspired by by that
expedition I I spend I've told the story
before but I spend half the week in
downtown LA cuz I've got a daughter that
goes to high school down there and it's
too far to commute on the daily and I'm
used to running in the trails around
here and I kind of took it upon myself
like I've lived in Los Angeles for over
20 years but until last year I would
rarely go downtown there's this no
reason to and there's you know as you
know
Los Angeles is sprawling it's gigantic
and there's very little there's huge
patches of it that I've never been to
and know nothing about and so I've taken
it upon myself to better connect with my
environment and when I do my runs
downtown it's it's all city streets and
I try to take different routes and I'll
go through like we're right on the edge
of Skid Row so I always run through Skid
Row and I'll run around MacArthur Park
which are places that you know everyone
will tell you don't don't go there and I
found the people you know to be like
really friendly and these are people
with not they're living in tents on the
street you know and I get high fives and
they recognize me now and like there's
like a friendly kind of like rapport
there whereas when I go on the trails
around here like I'll wave to somebody
running on the tree and they don't even
wave back right you know and I'm like
that's not right right right you know
there's so much to be learned if we can
set aside our fears and our judgments
and and open ourselves up a little bit
not to say that I've done anything like
what you've done I've just had a small
taste of that yeah what that experience
must be like and I don't know I mean I
don't know what the benefit is but I
know that there is a benefit to stepping
outside of our comfort zones and looking
people in the eye and and I think it's
it it works both directions I think that
it
makes those people feel more human you
know when you're sleeping on the street
in the middle of down downtown LA you
you can feel less and less like a human
and it makes you and me feel more human
as well and and tap into this empathy
that that I think can go a really long
way in our yeah and this time in our
society and something that perhaps we're
losing a little bit and it's a good way
to to kind of gain it back a little
we need more empathy more impactful in
the air and empathy and humility I think
are key stones for a better future
absolutely one of your main goals or the
impetus behind the the trans Americana
run was to inspire people that helped
them realize like hey this is this is
doable $1,000 a month that whole thing
but did you but kind of ironically the
the run every street thing has been the
template that has been copied and
emulated by you've created like a social
movement now there are people all over
the world who are doing their version of
what you've done and there's news
articles about it like that guy there
was a guy in Scotland I think who was a
kickboxer who then did he tried to do
what you did in his own town so that has
to be really cool to see kind of like
the the ripple effect of that it's
awesome yeah yeah it's so like I don't
follow much on social media but I do
follow the every single Street hashtag
uh-huh and it's just so cool to be able
to see like on like outwardly they're
not the most amazing photographs or or
accomplishes accomplishments on a day to
day basis but you keep kind of going
through these and you're realizing like
no you're just seeing a normal person's
version of where they live I mean you're
fertilizing these seeds that are that
are planting the fruit of Greater
connectivity and community because of
the the more people that are doing that
the more connected they are like they're
having their version of your experience
which is uniting people
bringing them together totally there was
a pit there was an article about a group
in in Vancouver that did every trail in
Stanley Park right yeah I realize
there's like twenty four thousand
kilometers of trail and that's not
edible we're gonna do every trail and
there's a big group photo of all of them
together like that's got to be amazing
yeah yeah it's awesome there's there's
one in there's a guy doing it in Brazil
in friend
just seeing the maps of the I think this
is like it's you know some of these
ideas they have to you know we have to
wait for that idea for everything to
come together for that idea to work and
right now our technology is is what is a
big part of what's allowing this project
to take off and I think the hunger and
the thirst that people have to be more
connected yep absolutely yeah on top of
that there are all these people doing
art projects on the graphing like the
mapping part of it to like you've been
sharing those on Twitter like totally
had like these little like I don't know
what you call them like motion graphics
oh yeah seeing the street you know they
like this like this map street art kind
of thing yeah and it's it's sort of
organic but like organic on a human
level which everyone like won an award
or something yeah yeah totally so this
is a gentleman in France who I gave him
all of the data from from my project and
he digitalized the entire thing so that
was just for for my data and the stuff
that's out there there's a guy in Zurich
doing every single street in suruc and
and he's got some really cool graphics
going along with that but just the
ability to wear a watch or wear your
phone and then to have the this strange
looking map of what you've accomplished
during that during the day to be able to
show like you know here's your photos of
the stuff that you saw and then here's
this strange looking map and it's and it
looks way different it looks with a
10-mile run in the city where you've got
this goal to cover all of the streets in
a small area can look so much more
impressive just on a graph
dick level yeah then a hundred-mile
point-to-point run yeah cuz one's just a
line and the other is this very
intricate detailed both accomplishment
of a run but also accomplishment of
human society and they created those
streets and and why are the streets in
that shape I feel like you should also
do like a taschen style coffee table
book with photographs and kind of the
graphics of the mapping and all of that
that tells the story in a more visual
way yeah working on it are you are every
tumor every single Street icon is that
up right away
I like that how do you how do you like
make your life work like you live a very
you're too mean to me you're the
definition of a minimalist like you keep
your overhead really low you keep your
life you conduct your life in a way that
allows you to do the things that you
love and you have sponsors that support
you and all of that but like what does
it look like on a daily basis sometimes
it's really exciting sometimes it's so
mundane that it's depressing um like
having running like I'm very fortunate
to have running as part of my daily
routine and I would say less so than it
was 10 years ago I used to be
obsessively like need to run every day
and now that's a little bit less and I'm
realizing that the less I run if I don't
have that routine then that the the
sooner that existential crisis comes in
and and that's usually a pretty good
indication that I need to put my shoes
on and get out for a run
but yeah the day-to-day is I don't know
it's uh I'm trying to figure I said it's
it's constant reinvention so some days
it's like I feel like I accomplished so
much whether that's on an artistic level
photographs
writing
coming up with ideas figuring out ways
to execute those ideas and then other
days it's like virtually nothing at all
but what's important is having the time
and the ability to to be able to do
those things right so yeah I don't know
does that answer your question yeah I
guess I mean I just you know I'm
interested in in and like how like
there's a lot of I think of you in a way
that's sort of similar to someone like
Laird Hamilton like he's created a life
out of surfing that has nothing to do
with competition and you emerged from
the competitive sphere of ultrarunning
to cut this very unique path that you
own and only you can do what you do and
you've been able to create a living out
of that which is like an amazing thing
like you get to basically do what you
want to do yeah and pursue the projects
that inspire you and that's like that's
a gift that's like a that's like this
rare liminal space that most people you
know can't access in their lives right
and so I mean you're I mean you're the
product of a hippie parent you know like
you that you were sort of raised to kind
of cut your own unique path I suppose in
many ways but were there ever times
where you thought like I gotta get a job
or like you know those moments of doubt
or yeah where your faith was questioned
about whether this is really like am I
gonna be able to do this I really it's
got to be hard yeah you know and I I
think that almost every single day yes
should I get a job right and it doesn't
be ever had a job like I've had a lot of
jobs I mean I worked waited tables over
10 or 15 years
I cooked distribute mezcal for a friend
of mine for a little while I for a
little bit there I was delivering food
in San Francisco and my motorcycle so
I've had lots of jobs and and more often
than not these jobs are to fill my day a
little bit and to meet people and and to
to pretty much to not be at home all day
long
and with with running as my only outlet
but in terms of running as a job
in these more recent projects it's it's
something you know when I decided to run
across the country a couple years ago it
was yeah it was just kind of a time in
my career where you know I I'm I'm not
gonna be Killian journée right at
anything like how many times you're
gonna tow the line it's some big race
exactly you know in like so many of
these races I can tell you from
experience like it's win or lose it's
like even though there's a podium even
if there's prize money ten deep it's
people only recognize that you've won or
lost which is a shame I think but it's
also just kind of the nature of the
beast and so in that sense I decided
like I want to start doing more
project-based runs that possibly inspire
people in a completely different way in
ways that I've personally been inspired
and so for that it's been these these
two projects that we've been talking
about I also put together a bunch of
running trips right cut run huh now I'm
now I'm getting confused no it's hot run
hi Ron huh and bus run bus uh-huh so
these are two like kind of like running
retreats right they're kind of running
retreats running experiences I'm still
trying to find the right label for them
but they they're small groups this
hut-hut running trip in Colorado
goes from Aspen to a small town outside
of Vail and we stay at these secluded
mountain huts the 10th mountain huts
which I grew up in Colorado maintaining
when I was starting at 16 years old I
was going in doing trail maintenance for
these huts and and you know he'd skied
from Hut to Hut and we biked from Hut to
Hut
there was never any trip that was a
running from about two Hut and so six or
seven years ago I came up with this idea
to do this and and vehicle assisted so
all you need is is your backpack a small
running pack and and then the ability to
cover fifteen to twenty miles a day
which is in most people's wheelhouse and
way more than people think and so I've
done I think thirteen or fourteen of
those Wow do you usually do two or three
a year and getting to meet people and
see people sort of transform during this
week when your cell phone doesn't work
and right you're really challenging
yourself and you're sleeping in 10,000
11,000 feet with not a lot of oxygen
yeah it's really quite exciting and so
it's it's kind of for me it's an
opportunity to provide a little bit of
my life in my philosophy for others and
you know I don't make people get rid of
their watches for the week but I
definitely suggest that they turn them
off and not pay attention too much just
we're gonna get there so if you had to
articulate that philosophy what is it
fun over fast that's that's generally
what I tell people and that yeah I think
that what it is is is really just
tapping into something way more
primordial that we've lost touch with a
little bit this simple you know coming
up with this simple goal and that's just
to keep moving all day long and then
when we get there we're gonna eat and
hang out and share some smiles and it is
getting back to something really primal
and I think that speaks to another like
hunger and thirst that we that we have
you know people are more interested in
having those kinds of experiences now
than go into a fancy resort total and
laying on a beach yeah like how can i
how can I just feel more
and and feel more alive right and we're
so accustomed to you know being in
offices and riding elevators and things
like that that we've we've lost that
connection yeah and what's the but the
bus run bus thing is is that it's kind
of a different version of that it's a
different version of that so I've got
some history of well I've got a lot of
history of road trips and a little
history of river rafting and so I kind
of consider it the the combination of
those two things being a traveler for
the past 20 plus years have known about
this bus company green tortoise out of
San Francisco they've been going since I
think the early 1970s 1973 the the
gentleman that started it converted a
school bus and drove people from San
Francisco to New York and he did the
first one in like four or five days and
then the second one he did in one week
and then the third one he did in three
weeks and he realized that the longer he
went the more people you could get to
sign up for and so now whatever it is 50
years later he's his son and his
grandson his son owns it his grandson is
a driver and they have a fleet of five
buses and they run trips all over the
place all over the American West up to
Alaska sometimes down into Mexico and
I'd known about them and I approached
them and asked if they could charter a
bus and do this trip San Francisco
Yosemite
Zion Grand Canyon Las Vegas Big Sur and
back to San Francisco in seven days and
the guy's eyes just lit up and he's like
that sounds amazing so basically you get
a bunch of Pete you sleep on the bus you
sleep on the bus you drive to a cool
place and you run around and then you
sleep and then go somewhere else exactly
so the bus drives through the night so
it's kind of I consider that kind of
like time travel uh-huh and you wake up
in a new place and wake up in Yosemite
and you go you've got ten
hours to to do a short run or ten hours
to do a long run whatever it is that you
feel comfortable with that's pretty cool
so the first one was this past summer
and we did that route that I just
mentioned and I had 25
I think runners on the bus to bus
drivers we covered one mile shy of 2,000
miles
uh-huh I think the the stronger runners
covered close to 140 miles throughout
the course of the week including like 15
mile run in Las Vegas hitting as many
restaurants as they could or the five
hours that we were there and yeah it was
just it was really phenomenal it was
living in the American West we have so
much at our fingertips
the issue is getting to all of them and
I so solve that with two bus drivers and
and a busload full of food and and a
bunch of like-minded that's pretty cool
so next summer I'm doing I'll do two of
those I'm gonna do one up in Alaska
which is really exciting so we'll fly
into Anchorage and fly out of Juneau
yeah and it'll be about fifteen or
sixteen hundred miles on the bus and
yeah potential again of 100 to 150 miles
running in all of those places through
some of the most beautiful terrain in
all of North America have you been up to
Alaska before I've I've gone up there
five five or six years in a row now yeah
oh yeah Wow yeah so I rode my motorcycle
up there six years ago to complete I was
one you did you rode your motorcycle all
the way to Patagonia right I rode my
motorcycle to Patagonia when I was 23
years old from Colorado I have this
tendency this need to to to do things a
little bit differently I'd gotten into a
study abroad program and Val pod ie so
Chile in central Chile I've been here
you have my wife is from Alaska
her mother is Chilean okay from Santiago
but I've been to Valparaiso and yes some
of the coastal towns around there
yeah it's incredibly beautiful and so I
had gotten into this study abroad
program and and just living in or being
being in school in Boulder Colorado for
you know however many years you get the
college students coming back and from
their study abroad program and and I was
just kind of hearing the same stories
over and over and over again and I'm
like alright I'm gonna do study abroad
but I'm gonna do it my way I'm gonna
ride my motorcycle there and so this was
a full ten years later I wanted to
complete the two continents so I rode my
motorcycle up to Alaska and then ran the
Mount marathon race up there which is
part of the reason that I I don't race
all that much anymore is because that
race is I consider to be the best out of
any race that I've ever done really
pretty much in the world why is that
it's dangerous it doesn't have a set
course it's extremely competitive it's
got a lot of history there's equal
emphasis on the men as their art is on
the women and on the juniors for that
matter and it's just a it's an
incredibly huge celebration of who we
are as Americans and who we are as
athletes it's really something that's
cool and it all has so it's not like a
lot nothing can match that so you're
just not it's hard I don't know how to
say it it's like it's hard it's like I
love I appreciate all of the races out
there I appreciate that there's these
races and I appreciate that that people
have something on their calendar to to
train for and to look forward to but
after running up and down
in Alaska like the idea of training to
run you know this contrived route around
a bunch of ski trails on a ski mountain
because that's the only place that we
can get a permit to run a race here in
the lower 48 it just doesn't do a whole
lot for me yeah like I said I I'm glad
that they exist but I need something
substantive to to kind of feed my my
desire to race yeah what's the point I
mean there's always somebody doing
something crazier - like how many times
can you run the bad water horse in a row
or totally you know the seven marathons
on seven continents and these are
expensive Affairs mm-hmm and your whole
thing is like that's great but let's
strip it away and we're and find the
meaning in all of this and the medium
comes in those human connections that
you have by just being in your backyard
yeah like it doesn't need to be more
complicated right yeah one of the things
we didn't talk about is the fact that
you lived in Antarctica for a while yeah
it was a while ago though right when
what when how old were you when you were
there and that was about those right
when Liz and I started dating so that
was maybe nine years ago and yeah I'm
lucky she's still in my life I left
frequently for several months at a time
[Laughter]
this is who you are
yeah and so this was like anti I had
read which book I mean every everyone
that's been to Antarctica has one book
that spoke to them more than the others
and a lot of people that books endurance
and other people it's another book and
for me it was this book called the worst
journey in the world and you would think
that would have the opposite effect
right instead this magnetizes you
completely and so this was a journey in
1906 or 1907 and it was it was the Scott
journey where he ended up going to the
South Pole and dying on the way back
this was written by the youngest person
on his team that stayed at camp and so
and so he was there in Antarctica for
two years I'm like I gotta go yeah and
yeah - very long winters and so an
ex-girlfriend of mine her ex-boyfriend
worked in Antarctica and I just asked
him like how do I get a job there he
said what's an escape you can't just go
now South Pole yeah unless you got a lot
of money and then you even then you
still can't stay for that long uh-huh
and so he's like so what what sort of
skills do you have and I'm like I don't
know he's like carpentry I'm like no
he's like kitchen and like sorta he's
like dishwashing I'm like I can wash
dishes
uh-huh and so that's what I did I went
it's the hardest job I've ever gotten in
terms of interviews and and physicals
and all of these things but yeah I got a
job at the South Pole I was on the first
airplane to go there for that season it
was October 12th must have been 2009 or
2010 and stuck around there for four
months washing dishes six days a week
ten hours a day ran two races while I
was there that was a huge part of the
reason that I wanted to go there's a
race called the race around the world
which takes place on Christmas Day
ever since the 1970s and it's a two and
a half mile race that goes around the
station and right and and pretty much
everybody participates whether on foot
or on snowmobile or on snow bikes or
whatever it is
some people tow couches behind the
snowmobiles it's just a parade around
the station it's an excuse for everybody
to get out didn't you create a new
course though I did yeah and so when I
arrived there they were doing three laps
three like 3/4 mile laps around the
station and I'm like but the station's
so much bigger than that like well how
come we don't go out to that you know
station or that building or that
building or out to the berms or out to
those you know the the ice tunnels out
there and the woman that I asked
it she handed me a map of the station
and said go ahead write who designed the
course and so I designed a new course
there just one broader one big one big
loop and it was awesome it in you know
went all around the station really cool
every time zone every time zone yeah
and then the winner of that race you the
the the Award for the man and the women
that win the race is that you get a free
trip to the edge of the continent to
McMurdo Station in order to compete in
the marathon there which is again only
open to employees and it's they usually
get maybe 40 or 50 people to run it and
on the day before that were supposed to
fly to McMurdo me and this gal they
cancelled our flight and it was just
weather just no it wasn't it was
bureaucracy they they had they didn't
need to any shipments to the South Pole
or vice versa so they they just
cancelled flight like we're not we're
not a priority the two skinny kitchen
staff runners wanting to run the
marathon on the coast was not enough of
a priority so we enlisted the help of a
couple surveyors at the South Pole
Station and we designed our own marathon
course there at the South Pole Station
which was again one lap of what we had
done about two and a half miles and then
out to the the ice runway which is two
and a half miles long and we did five
flaps up and down the ice runway for
dishes down and one woman we ended up
getting I think six or seven people
started and four people ran the marathon
from what I've been told it's still
going to this day and I think they get
like 15 to 20 people competing in the
marathon for hands-down quite possibly
the most boring marathon course in the
world definitely not the easiest as you
call it the Rickey gates marathon yeah
that's amazing so what are we looking at
like -20 my like what is the temperature
range it was when I did that it was mine
is that the the windchill was minus 40
and that was going one direction in the
other direction it was probably more
like minus 60 cuz I'm going with the
wind and then against the wind how do
you even gear up for the a lot of layers
yeah a whole lot of layers
I had big just like these guys big
earphones plugged into what was back
then and I I pod mm-hm and I just
remember this one funny part like and
huge mittens with glove warmers in there
I had my ipod on album shuffle and I
can't remember which album it was maybe
his greatest hits but Frank Sinatra's
greatest hits coming on and knowing that
the rest of your life here Frank Sinatra
you're exactly experienced straight
there and it was just I know that it was
too cold for me to take my ipod out
because it would have frozen immediately
and then I would have been without any
music so yeah listen like I think I'm
one of the few people that have listened
to an entire Frank Sinatra album while
running a marathon yeah but I had Colin
over 80 in here sharing about his solo
adventure across Antarctica pulling that
sled and he was saying that he had to be
very careful about how he expended
himself like you have to create momentum
to pull that sled but if he overexerted
himself or went too hard and started to
sweat like sweat his death can't sweat
so how do you run a marathon with all
these layers on and avoid that
death-defying pitfall yeah well you
can't run very fast that's for sure I
ran I think I ran 405 and it's it
there's no doubt about it it's a
delicate balance his situation was
vastly different than mine if I went
into death zone then I just ran into the
galley and got some hot chocolate right
he didn't have that
opportunity right but today I but as
soon as you start sweating it freezes
immediately totally and it was
fascinating like and that's when I
experienced it the most was during that
marathon was taking my jacket off and
there was actual like snow it's called
hor HOA are inside your jacket just all
of this frozen moisture and yeah it's
not something that you want to happen if
you're if you're out there from multiple
days or even like a really long day yeah
yeah it's deadly so what was the idea
going to Antarctica like what were you
trying to learn and did that experience
satisfy that totally it was two
different things I think that there's no
place on earth that's more like a
different planet than Antarctica so for
me it was like if I wanted to ever go to
space this was my opportunity to go to
space and then the other part is is
meeting and talking to all of the people
there that were equally as interested in
going to this other planet as me huh
it's just kind of funny the everybody it
seems like everybody goes down there
with a copy of dune and because and then
when you get there it feels very much
like this desert like it's the driest
place on earth it's 10,000 feet the
South Poles at 10,000 feet
it's pancake flat mmm there's like
without the station's there you're like
human beings can't exist there's no
life-form at the South Pole with the
exception of humans yeah I remember we
got our our fruits and vegetables in
from New Zealand at one point and there
was a ladybug
and the lettuce and the ladybug went
straight into a jar and it was the
station pet for the next three months is
incredible yeah
and everybody visited the ladybug that
was down in a little greenhouse but it's
just an interesting assortment of people
you get a lot of people like myself who
are travelers and they want to visit the
world you get some some old crusty
Antarctica people that uh you know
lifelong employees to the program
and then you get a few blue-collar
people as well you know working for the
contract company back then it was
Raytheon back then it was Raytheon and
now I don't know if this is still
current day but it's a Halliburton now
so boy what are they studying down there
they're studying things very very big
and very very small so they're studying
neutrinos this is the IceCube program
and so this is a really amazing
scientific experiment where they've
drilled 80 or so holes into the ice
Plateau and put these little detectors
dom's into the ice that can actually
detect when a neutron collides a
neutrino collides with the nucleus of an
atom and creates a small explosion and
so that's that's the things that are
really really small so these are they're
actually capturing
this explosion the Nutri neutrino goes
through the planet earth and then
collides on the opposite side so that's
how small they are
Wow yeah it's hard for me to realize
even yeah I can't even I can't even
understand without the yell and I had
like several different people dumb that
down for me in a lot of different ways
and that's that's the best way that I
understood that and then they've also
got some incredible telescopes looking
deep into outer space for dark matter
and then it being the cleanest air
supposedly the cleanest air on planet
Earth
they also study air quality Noah's there
with the station Wow
the stars at night had to be
unbelievable there was no so when I was
there I was there for this summer time I
watched the Sun revolve around IO or
Mont Street yeah I never saw it how does
that [ __ ] with you I had a room with no
windows in it and I simply put it into
my head that when I was going into my
room it was nighttime yeah she'd stick
to a schedule yeah yeah yeah
Wow also don't they like drill these ice
cores and pull them out and they're like
time machines right because they
literally they're so layer yeah I
usually like the rings of a tree like
you can go back in time 170,000 years is
how far you're going back when you're
going that far deep into the ice and so
you're looking you're looking at
explosion volcanic explosions right yeah
it's really incredible one of the things
I was reading about was with the
receding water levels in the melting of
the ice caps is that it starts to expose
like this water and ultimately vapor
from so long ago and they don't know
what's in that like they're mainly
viruses and bacteria that haven't been
on earth for hundreds of thousands of
years totally that could create yeah
strange sci-fi movies yeah yeah I'm
situation yeah that's a trip though yeah
so how do you now you're married you're
working on these books yeah but you're a
creature of wanderlust like once what's
next and how do you satisfy that itch
and yeah so now I'm still coming up with
more projects the project that I have
right now that I'm most excited about
which is going to take me a couple years
at least two years
I'm calling the 50 classic trails of
North America and this is kind of purely
up to me this is sort of based off of a
book from the 1970s called the 50
classic climbing a sense of North
America and where these two rock
climbers went around Canada Mexico
United States and and found these just
totally iconic rock climbs some of which
have only been done one time so for me
this is I want it to be a little bit
more attainable to the general public
but I do want it to be something that a
runner can strive for mm-hmm so the the
parameters for this are that I can tell
somebody with confidence that this trail
is worth traveling to and making a
weekend or we
out of it another parameter is that it
needs to be done in in 24 hours by the
fastest runners or hikers and tentative
of about calling it a running specific
book and then that it really covers all
ecosystems so I'm not gonna go through
all 50 of them but just a few of them
there's a couple obvious ones the the
rim to rim to rim and the Grand Canyon
is is an all-time classic and needs to
be included The Lost Coast in Northern
California 4050 mile point-to-point run
through the most uninterrupted coastline
in the lower 48 the one that I've done
most recently up in Alaska the Chilkoot
trail going from Skagway up into British
Columbia which was used for a couple
years for the the gold rush to get
people into the Yukon but then they
built a railroad which which bypassed it
but it's a 30 I want to say a 32 mile or
thirty four mile point-to-point run
which goes from this incredible coastal
jungle essentially up into this high
country and then down into a much more
arid Canadian landscape so the idea is
to kind of a few different things look
at a bunch of different ecosystems
provide people with hopefully some
inspiration to check out some new
terrain illuminate some some human
history ideally there's a bit of human
history with each of these trails and
and really provide something I call it
running beyond the bib providing people
with inspiration to to do a trail that's
not necessarily a race right and to give
them a goal that isn't necessarily an FK
T or a record but you know something
that that they can look at and
and feel like they they can accomplish
and this is a book that you're doing
it'll be book like if you like a like an
art book like a visual variable then
yeah yeah so this will be book website
and ideally one minute long per trail
little video toasts yeah like atlas
obscura fir-tree yeah totally yeah yeah
very cool yeah yeah I gotta get that guy
de to help illustrate I'm like his
illustration you have a lot going on
yeah like it's it's cool I just I think
I just what I really connect with about
what you're you're about is just is the
sharing part you know like how you're
taking this thing that you love and
creating like tactile objects and
inspiring people to you know infuse
their lives with the things that have
brought so much meaning to you it's
really cool yeah well thank you yeah
it's uh I I hope that it I hope that it
reaches people out there I know that die
I constantly need the things in my life
to evolve and I don't need to change
those things necessarily or like switch
out running for whatever skydiving or
something uh-huh but I do need for for
for it to evolve to to help me with who
I am today and you know I'm becoming
tomorrow well cool man I think that's a
good place to end it super amazing thank
you for sharing today trans Americana
coming to a film festival near you and
hopefully a digital platform at some
point I was very moved by it you guys
did an amazing job on that movie so
congratulations on that I can't wait for
people to see it and enjoy it thanks so
much yeah and what's the book and then
if you called the book is gonna be
called cross country and it's being
published by Chronicle Books out of San
Francisco and that'll also be out in
April in April cool and Ricky Gates calm
yeah definitely go to his website like
it's R it's a cool experience to just
get lost in all the content there it's
very cool and you're an easy guy to find
on social media it's amazing
photographer as well so definitely
subscribed year
you your Instagram page are key gates as
well anything else that's about it I
hope to share the trails with with
people hot run hot bus run bus I I love
providing these experiences and sharing
them with others so yeah I want to go on
one of those please do yeah you and I
have a mutual friend Heidi Zuckerman you
know Heidi that's right from Aspen
totally oh my goodness she was
interested in in a hot run hut and I'm
still working on it
oh wow yeah well I want to go
irrespective but Heidi's going I would
love to be able to join her at the same
time that would be really fun yeah she
just left the museum in Aspen did she
did she's shuttle back to New York I
don't know where she's gone
but I think she's I don't doubt that
there's a little bit of finding herself
right now uh-huh
that's that must be very exciting she
was at the Aspen Art Museum for 14 years
long time created a really incredible
program their new building it's I can
say this as a person that was born and
raised in Aspen that like her impact has
changed the face of the town for the
better and the and deeply cultural yeah
she's a very cool person so hey Heidi
I'm sure you're listening she might be
listening anyway
cool man well to be continued and and
again I just want to extend an invite
for you to come back and talk about the
book when when that's coming out and
maybe we can go on a run that time too
awesome
all right sounds great thanks so much
good talking to you
[Music]